organisiert werden diese Corona Proteste
und Krawalle immer wieder über telegram
über diesen Messenger Dienst telegram
also der Plattform für Hetzer unser
BILD-Reporter Peter Wilke war auf den
Spuren von telegram und die Armin auch
nach Dubai geführt
telegram tut nichts gegen die Dauer
Hetze von Falschinformationen bis hin zu
Morddrohungen gegen Ministerpräsident
Kretschmer auf telegram ist dafür Platz
denn die Betreiber ignorieren deutsches
Recht Kooperation mit den Behörden
Fehlanzeige Bild ging deshalb auf
Spurensuche in Dubai hier sitzt telegram
zumindest dem Anschein nach ja wir sind
jetzt in 23 Stockwerk des all casinos
hier in Dubai ganz genau in Paula im
Hintergrund sehen wir das büro
2301 dahinter soll telegram sitzen so
glaub es zumindest das Bundesamt für
Justiz die haben nämlich im früher schon
das Anhörungsschreiben hierhin geschickt
aber wenn man sich das anschaut
erscheint das sehr schwierig bis hin zu
unmöglich hier einen Brief zuzustellen
wir probieren es trotzdem mal und werden
jetzt anklopfen und mal sehen ob jemand
öffnet
eine Mitarbeiterin vom Empfang berichtet
dass sie von telegram das letzte Mal
2019 jemanden gesehen habe die Büros
sein leer wie soll hier jemals ein Brief
zugestellt werden wir haken nach
die Rechtshilfeersuchen an die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate zur
Veranlassung der Zustellung der
Anhörungsschreiben des Bundesamtes für
Justiz an den Anbieter
sind noch nicht abgeschlossen
die Mahnung der deutschen Behörden hat
die Verantwortlichen nie erreicht
telegram Extremisten ein warmes zu Hause
denn für die Behörden ist die Plattform
ein unerreichbarer Gegner
und wir brechen jetzt live mit unserem
Reporter Peter Wilke der vor wenigen
Tagen noch in Dubai war jetzt aber
wieder zu Hause in Düsseldorf ist Peter
beschreib doch noch mal die Atmosphäre
da in diesem Tower vor dieser Tür war
das gespenstisches kam zumindest ein
bisschen so rüber
ja das war tatsächlich erst mal
überraschen einen so großen Unternehmen
einen so viel genutzt sind taktform wie
telegram mittlerweile über 570 Millionen
Nutzer hat die Plattform dort in der
Form anzutreffen nämlich gar nicht das
einzige was wir dort eben gesehen haben
waren diese
Holztüren verschlossen verrammelt dort
hat niemand geöffnet kein Klingelschild
kein Logo kein Briefkasten nicht zu
sehen also eine ganz klassische
Briefkasten für Maja und das war
tatsächlich ein bisschen mysteriös in
diesem Tauern in den genauen unterwegs
waren insgesamt 53 Stockwerke haben die
sitzen auch viele andere
Internetunternehmen unter anderem
linkedin eine bekannte Plattform aber
auch tiktok und da wir auch in den Büros
vorbeigeschaut und die sahen sehr viel
offener aus also da waren tatsächlich
auch Mitarbeiter vor Ort die waren
richtig eingerichtet werden diese groß
wohl halt eher leer sind und man ebenda
in Dubai von dem geringen steuern
profitieren kann man da auch mit Leuten
gesprochen wird das erklärt haben wir
1000 € kann man da einfach so einen
Schein Sitz eröffnen also das ist der
Schein Sitz gewesen in Dubai da hast du
niemanden gefunden aber gibt es
irgendeine Spur die zudem Pawel durow
dem russischen Mark Zuckerberg dem
Gründer von telegram führt hast du
irgendeine Spur gefunden ja die Spur ist
relativ offensichtlich er postet ganz
selten ab und zu auf seinem
instagram-account Fotos von seinem Leben
und erscheint auch tatsächlich selber in
Dubai zu leben aber eben nicht in diesem
Büro zu arbeiten er selber sagt das
telegram so rund 25 Mitarbeiter weltweit
habe und die dann auch von weltweit von
überall aus sozusagen Remote arbeiten
können es sind ein paar andere
Mitarbeiter geben eben auf LinkedIn z.b.
auch anders sie in Dubai sitzen es wird
aber auch spekuliert dass Mitarbeiter in
St. Petersburg arbeiten also in der
Erinnerung von den russischen
Ursprungsland aber insgesamt sollen die
Welt wann sind unterwegs sein mehr ist
da aber noch nicht bekannt die Spur von
Pavel durov dem Gründer führt aber
jedenfalls bis nach Dubai der trifft
sich dort auch sehr gerne mit denen mit
der königlichen Familie hat sich doch
Anfang des Jahres mit einem Erbprinzen
getroffen also der scheint sich da
pudelwohl zu fühlen den Luxus zu
genießen eben aber auch die
Steuerfreiheit aber auch dass die
Deutschen würden ihn dort nicht
erreichen kann und kannst du ihn haben
danke Peter Wilke auch für deine
Recherchen von Vorort besten Dank und
bei uns im Studio sitzt unser
Bildschärfe Johannes Boye Johannes man
hat das Gefühl wir Deutschen unser Staat
ist einfach machtlos gegen diese Hesse
in dieser auf dieser Plattform Telegramm
sein sollen genauso ist es zunächst mal
muss man festhalten hätte und auch hast
sind vom Grundgesetz gedeckt es ist
fällt unter die Meinungsfreiheit ich
darf in diesem Land Herzen ich darf
hassen das ist eine umpo Bolero Aussage
aber sie ist ein Teil der Wahrheit die
Frage ist wie viel Hass und Hetze und in
welchem Ausmaß verträgt das unsere
Demokratie und verträgt das unsere
Gesellschaft den bislang vor dem
Internet und vielleicht auch vor
Telegramm war es doch so du hattest in
jedem Dorf in jeder Mord an zwei drei
Leute die hatten eben radikale
extremistische Meinungen Seilzug Corona
damals ganz vielleicht Corona noch nicht
oder sein ist politisch extremistische
Meinung die saßen dann nicht spreche mal
sehr sinnbildlich alleine in der
Eckkneipe hunters dort verbreitet und
sind dann alleine wieder nach Hause
heute kommen all diese Menschen zusammen
in Telegramm Gruppen primär in Telegramm
Gruppen wir sehen das Problem auch auf
anderen Plattformen aber vor allem in
Telegramm Gruppen und dort geht daneben
münde diese Hetze und dieser hat dann
eben auch in klar strafrechtlich
relevanten Sachen aufrufen zur Gewalt
Ablehnung des Staates und so weiter und
so fort und das ist ein Phänomen dem
sich Deutschland im sieht die deutsche
Gesellschaft jetzt ausgesetzt sieht und
die Frage ist was können wir dagegen
machen bei Telegramm ist die Wahrheit
bislang überhaupt nichts denn die Firma
hat Peter Wilke unsere Partei hat es
rausgefunden nicht mal eine
ladungsfähige Anschrift das heißt hat
sächlich auch unsere neue Regierung und
der neue Justizminister ist da hilflos
während andere Plattformen ja
kontrolliert werden zumindest innerhalb
der möglichen des Möglichen Rahmens ist
man bei telegram völlig hilflos hilflos
letzten Endes nicht denn man wird
technische Möglichkeiten ausschöpfen
können um das um diese Plattform
theoretisch zu verbieten aber man
befindet sich zunächst mal in einer
hilflosen Lage nämlich in Hinblick auf
die politisch-gesellschaftliche
Diskussion die dem vorgelagert ist und
dass es eben dann die Frage wie viel
Meinungsfreiheit wollen wir zulassen
was ist erlaubt in diesem Land und was
ist nicht erlaubt ich bin selber viel
auf Telegramm guck mir an was dort läuft
und sie eben auch das zweischneidige
Schwert wir haben einerseits Gruppen aus
Autokratien aus Diktaturen
wo man wirklich sieht da trifft sich die
Opposition da trifft sich der Widerstand
der vielleicht in einem Land
natürlich außerhalb Deutschlands in
einer Diktatur verfolgt werden würde wir
sehen aber auch in Deutschland die
Gruppen von Bodo Schiffmann lange Zeit
die Gruppe von Attila Hildmann dass es
einfach Antisemitismus das sind Aufrufe
zur Gewalt dass es Ablehnung des Staates
und
deswegen würde ich hier immer
unterscheiden was in manchen Ländern
vielleicht ein hilfreiches Mittel ist
ist in Deutschland leider vollkommen
abgedriftet und wird primär verwendet um
für die Demokratie sehr schwierige
Sachen auszutauschen Wer ist nicht eine
ganz einfache Lösung einfach diese App
Telegramm aus dem App Stores
rauszunehmen das wäre zumindest ein
politischer Ansatz. Das wäre sicher auch
durchsetzbar wenn der Gesetzgeber
entsprechendes verbietet müssten die für
den die App Stores gehören also in dem
Fall Apple oder primär Apple die haben
ja eine ladungsfähige Anschrift von
denen wir wissen wir wer Sie sind die
müssen dann diese Apps rausnehmen das
ist eine technische Lösung aber man muss
die gesellschaftliche Debatte führen
möchte
danke an den Bildschirm Johannes Boye
bei uns hier im Studio über den
Messenger Dienst telegram der im Moment
dient auch zur Verabredung eben bei
diesen Corona Spaziergängen die uns im
Moment so sorgen bereiten weil sie so
oft gekapert sind von Neonazis von
Hooligans